[Musique]
ce jeudi 28 avril a lieu la deuxième
édition des ulises yade au complexe
sportif de casabona à saint-pierre
une rencontre sportive réunissant les
élèves des classes ulis unité locale
pour l'inclusion scolaire dans les
collèges à l'église at c'est le
rassemblement des collégiades différents
régions de l'île qui
son panthéon handicap plus des
déficiences tant que fonction cognitif
et qui fait du sport 30 ans et de misère
à toutes les cotes bien content quand on
est en situation d'handicap de pouvoir
faire du sport et de faire du sport en
santé on va on va peut-être passion le
sport de compétition mais sport santé
dans un premier temps et après dans la
zone de zones tampons certains vers la
compétition
de 140 jeunes des quatre coins de l'île
ont participé à ce challenge
départemental organisé par la ligue du
sport adapté de la réunion en
collaboration avec le conseil
départemental et d'autres partenaires
le sport et la culture sont deux piliers
importants de l'éducation de l'insertion
et là on voit des professeurs dynamiques
les encadrent des bénévoles on voit un
président dynamique et nous réactivité
ou leur apportons et moyens nécessaires
pour aller jusqu'au bout de la projet
cogez c'est souvent des projets des
cours de collège des projets aussi deux
clubs les des projets personnels et
nous accompagnons ça notre activité
toute cette dynamique
pour que nos jeunes soient vraiment à
leur place et qu'ils soient et paris
et en même temps c'est préparer aussi
les jeux paralympiques
basketball hommes ball tennis de table
ou encore athlétisme étaient au
programme des collégiens qui ont
apprécié la journée
j'adore les activités cargo l'apf
la moitié les
jeter la voiture des jaunes des
retraites avec la jolie toile et dénonce
un copain lui coquine et plus
c'est bien la seule femme faisait bien
jouer avec les copains à bien l'aimer
je suis
alors le but qu'on veut c'est de pouvoir
se rencontrer rencontrer d'autres élèves
qui sont dans le dispositif aussi
d'autres jeunes en situation de handicap
comme eux et ça lui permet de s'épanouir
en fait dans le sport de découvrir
certaines disciplines un haut niveau du
sport adapté puisque comme laon avec un
goal connaissent pas donc ça donne envie
de
d'essayer et de voir si ça leur plaît
pour ensuite broutards peut-être faire
partie d'un club et participer aux
championnats de la réunion par exemple
voilà
une journée ludique qui a permis aux
élèves de découvrir et pratiquer des
activités sportives d'être ensemble et
de partager l'esprit des clips
[Musique]